hello hey John
Tim Dylan how are you thanks so much for
taking my call buddy how are you doing
doing good man long long time since
religion class man long time yeah I mean
John what high school together and
you're you're a doctor right you're I I
think you're even like a respiratory
therapist or something
yeah respiratory therapist yeah what's
going on out there
in terms of the severity level of this
and how our hospital is responding I
mean you're kind of on the frontlines
you're you're see yeah yeah what what is
this looking like I mean what it's
looking like is you're having people
quarantined off I'm a respiratory
therapist so I mean we're the ones that
know how to access these ventilators you
know I week you hear about you know
ventilators are in short supply they are
and a ventilator is basically explain to
people what a ventilator is if they
don't know a ventilator is a machine
that helps breathe for a patient when
someone has to be intubated and placed
on a machine it breathes for them when
they're too sick to breathe so a machine
breathe for you that's really what it is
and then ways in terms what do you hope
happens to that person while they're
being ventilated so that they can take
over breathing on their own what is it
is it that they just they're there
you're giving their body time to heal
their immune systems fighting this off
them yeah absolutely
yeah you're given that mutism time to
recover you by a patient time and you
know when you have an infection in the
lungs especially you need time to heal
eventually what happens though is the
lungs if they don't heal you can
basically just be on the ventilator
until until you die sadly how are you
seeing patients come in with this
disease and are they are they very sick
are they have mild symptoms are you
seeing everything in between you're
seeing a lot of people coming in with
coughing coughing a lot you're seeing a
lot of people come in again flu you know
right Korona virus very flu-like so
we're not really sure right away as soon
as they come in they're getting tested
you know we have you know the cold in
nineteen protocol actually at our
Hospital where people are you know
coming in being tested be basically like
isolated immediately so they're getting
isolated immediately and being
quarantined to a specific floor I
actually we started with about and we
started with about maybe three four
patients a couple days ago now we're
already up to 16 at our hospital okay
now 16 people that are admit now what is
the criteria whether you're admitting
somebody or like who is getting these
tests because you keep hearing that
people are saying I go and I'm unable to
be tested because I don't meet the
criteria so what is your criteria to
actually test somebody for this disease
for the disease well they really have to
be they're sneezing a lot they're
coughing a lot I mean but that could be
you know mask is anything that's why
it's so tough like you said to find
these tests and to get these tests
because you know it looks like other
diseases you know you don't even know
that it's the corona virus so you do get
the test so on it is difficult and and
and another thing ten is actually the
the mass shortages I'm seeing in the
hospital you're getting a lot of
personal protective equipment for people
they don't know what that is
it's mask n95 masks which are more you
know they're better for the corona virus
because it protects against droplet
transmission right so shortage of them
are they made in China is that a supply
chain they are they are I actually I
looked at in that Morrow that's a supply
chain that's funny how things work yeah
yeah so you go into the hospital and
like recently the hospital said listen
you know we're on such a mass shortage
you know they don't even have the n95
currently they have we're using yellow
masks which are you know not as not as
protective so it's very scary I mean
you're really on the front lines and
you're really seeing this mass shortage
and
I don't know you just have to kind of
make do and you just hope you don't get
it yeah do you anticipate getting this
do most healthcare workers believe they
will
eventually I would say so and that is
pretty accurate actually that's pretty
accurate yeah I mean we've I mean I've
been a therapist for what nine years and
you know pretty healthy exposed to this
stuff daily so I mean you don't even
know if you haven't announced him you
could add last week listen I got
diagnosed a week and a half ago
I wonder I went into an urgent care they
said I took a strep test they said I was
positive for strap right yeah I went
home they gave me a you know antibiotics
I took the antibiotics but I was
coughing and I felt like [ __ ] and and a
lot and I was like you know coughing is
not really a symptom of strap right it's
just not so you know I'm like maybe I
had it and then I'm still I still have a
little light cough like every now and
then you know yeah very corona yeah so
when I drink when I drink water or I eat
the cost a little worse why is that bad
why does your cough get worse if you
drink or something probably because a
little bit you know you're drinking a
little bit it's going down your airway a
little bit maybe you're not getting it
but I mean dude I wasn't sleeping well I
felt like [ __ ] but now I seem to be I'm
on the other side of it I'm over it I
have you know my temperature two weeks
ago was ninety nine point four now it's
back to ninety seven nine so yeah you
probably a lot of elderly people a
during that period some quarantine I was
pretty much in my apartment taking my
medication just hanging out podcasting
but my podcast producer who sits right
next to me right has felt fine so
wouldn't he have gotten it or maybe not
see some it's just some people like
they'll have it and they don't even
realize they have it miss we grow like
super healthy again like I said I might
have it right now I don't even know I'm
just hand washing and again trying to
wear it mask and cover up as much as I
can but because I don't know I you know
that the hospital workers at my hospital
have not been tested
you hear these horror stories where like
a friend of Mines father 63 years old
marathon runner guy he lives in Seattle
he got it and he would died four days
later and then you hear then you hear of
people that have it and don't know that
they have it what makes the difference
because this guy didn't seem to have any
underlying conditions or a compromised
immune system he wasn't a smoker why are
some people responding to this so
severely where it's killing them within
eight days and why are some people
barely noticing symptoms is that is that
something we can even discern I don't
think we have enough information yet to
even discern that like because sometimes
like Bill they'll say that always
airborne
you know transmission of this and then
they'll say it's droplet meaning you
have to be coughed on or seized on you
know like when you're coughing on old
people and these are no people 10 that
is like they need to have actually your
droplet onto them in order to get this
other people are saying I could be in
you know or close to you and I'm just
breathing and you guys and I get it and
I walk right into your you know your
your airborne right where your air is
right so it's a very very you know scary
really very scary to risk to see that
you could you know be doing that and in
the hospital everyone's close together
there's tons of sick patients that's
where you're all in that air so do you
think hospitals are gonna be able to
keep up with this or is this going to be
something that kind of collapses the
healthcare system honestly I think it's
gonna get a lot worse I really do I
think it's you know me you don't need
your positive guy your super positive
guy like always on like they've always
you know but I honestly think that it's
going to get worse you're going to see
more people getting sick I mean in a
couple days women from like 1 to 16 I
mean that's just a couple days so next
it'll be 34 you know we're gonna have
hundred cases so you just hope that they
don't get sick enough to where they do
require ventilatory support at that
point you know Italy is a real nightmare
yeah we don't want to end up like Italy
absolutely right and that's why I'm
telling everyone
stay home quarantine yeah yeah yeah what
do you think people should do if they
think they have it should they not go to
a hospital I mean if you think you have
it like you're saying you're coughing or
sneezing you're I mean not nothing and
that's so much me because I feel for you
like I've known her I feel you know but
let's say you wake up tomorrow and you
have a fever you have chills you're
coughing and you have flu-like symptoms
what do you do do you just wait it out
in your apartment I mean I wouldn't
honestly I'm going to the doctor right
you got kids you have to get help for
yourself you have to get help for
yourself because if you're just going to
sit there and you know continue to get
worse and worse like I mean I've had the
flu like the regular flu like yours back
and you need help and you need
medication you know you need to get
better otherwise you're not your body
doesn't have enough of an immune system
sometimes when you're sick to fight it
are there over-the-counter things you
can take ibuprofen things like that and
no that's that's not that's not good
enough
that's just so when you come in with
corona what are they giving you oh man
what are they giving you and like the
actual medication yeah I mean they're
honestly like from a rut I can only tell
you from robust for example and I can't
tell you from a medical thing like you
know what these are the things
yeah but respiratory wise we're very
worried again about the droplets and the
transmission so normally we put patients
on like a nasal cannula which is just
like a little device in their nose in
order you know if they need supplemental
oxygen and then normally we have other
devices we go did we go to like bypass
like little machines and opti for high
flows of that we don't even want that
we're just going from an optic from a
nasal cannula straight to like this
thing called a non rebreather which is
basically just like 100 percent oxygen
and then straight the intubation so if
they don't want to spread the
transmission of that so that's that's
actually pretty important about
antiviral drugs like REM DES aveer which
they say is you know is speeding up
going a clinical you know human trials
second round that's had some six almost
are treating here maybe
some success but I don't think enough is
out there to know with that actually you
know there's not enough cases not enough
studies to see that you know Ren des
aveer is effective and again it's it's
unprecedent and more the time where we
just don't even know what this is you
can't even you can't even side of that
right do you as somebody who's worked
with all kinds of you know diseases and
things like that do you believe that
this is worse than we've been led to
believe because you know that the news
media has kind of been like it's a flu
it's only offending old people is that
is that something that you think when we
look back on it you think that we kind
of didn't quite understand how bad this
was and how widespread its effects were
now we're seeing younger people yeah I
think absolutely I think you've hit the
nail on the head about that I think it
is there are young people that again may
not show symptoms of it but they do have
it and you know we don't have the
testing for right now but they are do
they do happen and they aren't spreading
it so and but it shows up in the elderly
population so there's also supposedly
there's young people getting sick and
are being hospitalized even young people
yeah yeah I was I heard from another
hospital that's very close to us and
sanity where they had a 20 it was a 27
year old intubated and vented because of
the corona virus I know I know we were
all across at that point when you're
intubated and you're on a ventilator
what is the time that they give you to
get better before I mean are you
conscious when you're on a ventilator or
now usually not because it's a very you
know I mean you it's really you're you
have a tube in your throat and the vent
is pushing the breath into your lungs
it's actually pushing the breath into
your lungs for you that's right we
normally breathe their negative pressure
well I snuck in and and breath comes out
with a ventilator pushes positive
pressure into you so it's the opposite
way at which we breathe so that's a 27
year old that's unconscious you know in
sort of a coma would you call it a
medically induced coma I would and
they're on a ventilator how
long do you give that person before that
you have to give that ventilator to
somebody else yeah well first of all you
have to see if their body's healing
because as a respiratory therapist you
know we're constantly monitoring oxygen
and co2 levels in their blood and seeing
keeping your blood based balance your pH
normal okay yeah so that's so we're
monitoring that we're monitoring how
you're healing and but sometimes you
become too sick we you know we try to
wean you off this ventilator again the
ventilator buys you time ventilator
respirator same thing it buys you time
when you're too sick and you're too you
know your body can't overcome this
they usually I mean you have to
sometimes get a tracheostomy let me put
a hole in your neck back back that's an
option okay well then you're on well it
just there's a tube in your throat and
if they can't you know take the tube
from your throat they put a hole in your
neck to like like facilitate and help it
just how it's much easier to breathe
that way yeah so so that's one thing but
eventually it would make it sick enough
that they're going to die nominally
there's nothing more we can do yeah is
there a length of time is that five days
is that two weeks is that three days it
really divided the body you know and
never wants to die it always he's gonna
try to survive so so you're gonna have
to make a call unfortunately and saying
this is not looking good yeah you just
say listen we've exhausted all options
you say something like you know we think
that we've exhausted all options here
the progression of disease has gotten
worse you know we're beyond you know
we're beyond the point of you know them
coming back from it's sad but you know
that's something that people are gonna
have to take you know some steps we're
gonna have to take and there's going to
be a lot more people a lot more people
affected by that so this is not I mean
you know people keep saying a lot of
people die from the flu every year which
also shocked me when somebody said fifty
or seventy thousand people die from the
flu I wish
that was that's like the first thing
when anyone so talked about this that's
the first thing they say all people die
the flu over here but it's just like
this is different this is something
completely different but you have the
world hasn't seen exactly the world is
seeing what their what's happening with
Italy and yeah so do you have any hope
for uh you know the antiviral drugs
getting better soon is there anything is
it hard to say I mean honestly I think
it could take a year this is a year of
this again it's gonna get worse I really
firmly believe that and again like super
positive but I just think it's gonna and
you're at lilia work you're at least a
year away from or at least a year away
from the vaccine right I mean that's a
yes
yeah year away how long how long do you
think businesses stay closed and people
that go out I just don't like are we
gonna lock down the whole city
you know lock down the whole country
forever I mean what do you what do you
think the the thing is are we are we
eventually gonna have to within a month
or two months or something say we're
gonna have to kind of start going back
out again and then people normal well I
don't know I don't want to say normal
but like people are gonna go out and
just get it and develop an immunity and
I mean is that also a misnomer that
people that this heard like immunity is
gonna help or do you think people might
be able to get this again I think I
think people will get this again I think
we'll people will get this again and
we're going to go through a cycle right
I really if you said both the ball one
you believe I say that we're gonna go it
was like one it's gonna be like like you
said the flu like oh you got your flu
shot make sure you get your flu shot I
feel like people will I don't know what
your body's going to be also when they
test him I don't know what the
coronavirus if you know we don't know
imagine being the first person imagine
signing up to be the first person for
the corona virus it's an experimental
vaccine but I mean like Tim you would be
a prime candidate I would be about I
would absolutely be a prime candidate
what do you say is there any is there
any truth to the idea that
in the warmer months this the
transmission might drop what
what about warm weather makes the body
less hospitable to germs or viruses or
whatever I don't think there's anything
to that honestly I think people are
hoping that yeah I think they're hoping
like oh we're gonna hope for that but
you know the virus Konev are can live on
surfaces for days you know and it stays
in the air so it doesn't have it's hot
or warm air and dry humid you know if
it's gonna be out there it's gonna be
out there I don't think the heat you
know the coronavirus my love the heat
for all we know we don't know enough
about it I don't know any yeah that's
the scary thing what is it is yeah god
it might get worse in and make it worse
so it's like you don't any like exactly
the heat it's like you hear people say
that - I mean that's like a common like
you know just the heat'll it will be
it'll make you better not necessarily
not necessarily we don't know you you've
been very positive I mean this is a very
you know we're very what's this what's
the good what's the good news
any is there any good news
ah let's think people are closer
together I guess people go through there
they're all kind of like in this
together you know when you see you go to
the supermarket the girls in it just
like you know the majority of people who
get this are not gonna die and they're
not gonna require hospitalization is
that still what we believe that's what
we believe
exactly listen I'm on the front line
seen the sickest of people so you're
right you know like again that you might
have right now I might have a sign we're
healthy
we're fine are the people you're seeing
are the majority of them are older
majority are older I'd say like 70s
again it was at Valar they're like 27
year old but other than that I'd say
like 70s 80s maybe a 60s a couple
sixties actually a couple sixties but
yeah 60 seventies eighties are you guys
at the hospital working extra shifts er
these are shorter workers actually you
guys are working them absolutely they're
dying for people if they are dying for
and of course you know what the health
care the police we work at and stuff a
lot of people calling out sick because
they don't want to get sick I mean is it
is it possible that maybe I go in there
and
do a few surgeries you know I've watched
a lot er Chicago Hope you know listen
you should absolutely apply I would say
stat I could say 10 cc's of this that I
think would help to have me in there
just in a coat kind of walking around
yes I think people would feel at ease
when they thought everybody stopped
smoking weed you know everyone smoking
weed now and you're a respiratory guy I
mean obviously cigarettes are we all
know they're bad but weed is not good
either yeah exactly because it's a
sexier you know your alveoli the line
these lungs everything so it's listen
like that these all other can of worms
right but does that affect people you
know if you're a young person and you're
a smoker this has more of a chance of
affecting you than a non-smooth
affecting you I mean if you think
smoking weed any of this smoking
anything any of the weed like vaping any
of that any of that because it's I mean
any vaping that do cigarettes is
affecting your your the lining of your
lungs your alveoli there's a small
little air sacs so yes in in short term
yes it's going to affect you have you
seen our people that are recovering from
this a lot of people say they're having
lasting effects what kind of lasting
effects are people have laughing last
long-term effects of having this disease
long-term effects
well personally for me I haven't seen
the lasting effects because I find
people you know on the ventilator and
stuff but I mean I can imagine you know
your body goes through your lungs
especially are going through you know
like trauma you know you're finished
lung capacity things like that yeah your
your frc functional residual capacity
like old yeah exactly like the lining is
your lungs because because what happens
is your white blood cells they totally
go into your long they you know they're
getting attacked right so you're trying
to fit your body is naturally trying to
defend this whatever virus it is could
be anything you're trying to defend it
in actuality it's like flooding your
lungs are are the caught they say
there's a dry cough now what does that
mean versus like a phlegmy coughing if
you're coughing up phlegm does that mean
you don't have this or now that would be
yeah they'll be like a wet cough exactly
a dry cough is just you know you're dry
you you started there's nothing there
there's no moisture no more your wet
cough mean you don't have Corona no no
no it's not like that not like that so
yeah you could be coughing up phlegm and
still very much have it absolutely yeah
yeah yeah it's not always just like we
don't look like oh that's a dry cough I
know that's a wet saw this could be
corona no it's just like no they're
different different different aspects is
your wife worried about it is she kind
of worried yeah yeah definitely yeah how
is Long Island how is Long Island
feeling now that everything is kind of
shut down are people like heeding the
warnings and staying inside or are
people being idiots no I think well
people are people will always be idiots
them you know Long Island Long Island
well I know you know well I know we were
there for a couple years yeah yeah but I
say people are still being idiots yeah
but they're going out I mean but people
more you see more people with masks and
the n95 those are like gold we had to
lock those up yeah because people were
stealing them they were actually
Hospital care workers stealing that uh
yeah where they were taking that because
you know they didn't want to run out so
you know a couple nurses you think it
gets bad enough where health care
workers don't want to go in because they
don't want to get sick do you think
something like that happens yeah really
really absolutely I can tell you like
man to man absolutely where people are
like listen I don't want to get this
[ __ ] or especially if you have that
where you're covering that zone we're
gonna have to be with those patients I
think all that solutely it's reality
it's reality so see just like if they're
not also giving us the supplies and
they're not giving us the personal
protective equipment the n95 mask the
yellow gowns all that kind of stuff
everything we need do you want to be
exposed to this I mean you see what
Italy and you know China and stuff they
were working like super hazmat suits
right yeah what is is that yeah
that's now [ __ ] and that's why I ever
made thanks to me when people said oh
this is just a flu I'm like it's not the
flu there's people walking around in
hazmat suits yeah yeah exactly so like
some pictures of like Italy and you know
the Leaning Tower of Pisa with like
massive sprays you think that's like you
know gonna just we're going to be
protected with just a little and 95m
yellow I mean they make us wear like you
know goggles to protect your eyes
everything right so it's it this thing's
a nightmare and do you do you see a
2-month do you think the cases are gonna
get worse in the next eight weeks
instead of two month is it a six month
what are we looking at here in terms of
like when do you see the curve starting
to get flattened if you occur yeah like
hashtag the curve flatten I love that
yeah like something yeah we have to plan
that curve when's that when's that gonna
happen I mean we're doing social
distancing so if people are doing the
social distancing I mean that's that's
good
but honestly I could see a year ten I'm
serious yeah I could I feel like a year
till they start getting these
vaccinations out and they work and they
show that they work you know and you you
know liver doesn't explode or something
right you know when you take it yeah you
know it's unknown like an unknown drug I
mean like I said you should try it out
man no one's offering it but there's so
what I'm getting from you yeah we know
far less about this and we are
pretending to no I I would say that
that's accurate I would say that
accurate yeah because because it's just
we're just dealing with what the
symptoms and the people are coming in
and then you know one day it's droplet
now you got to wear this or the mask now
it's airborne I gotta wear 95 like
there's so many different things we're
just you know kind of flying by the seat
of our pants right now and it's air man
it really is because again like I'm on
the front lines I'm seeing this
firsthand you know yeah well listen man
I appreciate you calling is there any
advice for people out there just kind of
stay home you know listen listen social
distancing is a thing you know if you're
you're doing that I think you're you're
doing the right thing it's going to
it's gonna be really interesting to see
the any of these conspiracy morons on
the internet that the virus isn't real
you're here to tell them it's genuinely
real I mean I see it every day
like let's go to work like it's it's
real I mean you can there's always
conspiracy for everything Oh everything
this or whatever but right I mean I can
only tell you what I see it's absolutely
real there are shortages in masks and
personal protective equipment and we're
just learning right now me and you all
together everyone your listeners
everybody else is learning about you
know the effects every day we're
learning something new and the beds I
mean hospital beds are probably going to
be a problem too
yeah I mean we quarantine the whole
floor we had a specific floor where we
just have only Murano glass page
obviously isolation rooms were just one
you know one person but I mean you're
gonna have enough nurses respiratory
therapists you're gonna have enough
people for that I don't know I don't
think so and especially if people start
calling out more because they don't want
to get it so it's really tough right now
it's really tough not in the health care
worker well listen man you guys all my
[ __ ] you know I'm amazed dude I think
you guys have the second hardest job in
the country right now the first of
course is me as a podcaster I think I'm
entertaining everyone both the healthy
and the sick people and you guys are
really you're really just working with
the sick which is still a small
percentage so but I think you guys are
the second most important job in the
country and I thank you for doing it
yeah listen I appreciate it listen let's
get let's hopefully when I'm out in Long
Island we'll go and grab dinner or
something hopefully when this all blows
over all right man thanks so much but
that's a guy you know that I went to
school with me you know respiratory
therapist in a hospital in Long Island
you know doesn't seem to be making it up
you know doesn't seem to be an actor you
know it's bad out I mean there's no good
news
I mean there's not there's not only no
good news but like nobody knows what the
[ __ ] this is nobody knows who it kills
why when it'll let up if it'll get
better when it'll get better if it gets
bad like nobody knows anything
he was kind of honest he's like yeah you
know I'm in the frontline to this and we
just don't we don't know
you know we're flying by the seat of our
pants like everybody else you know it's
scary when you when you have a situation
like that I mean are you scared the only
thing he seems sure of was like it's
gonna last about a year he said it seems
like a batty well 20 20s over yeah 20
21s to move I mean 20 20 is legitimately
over there is nothing left here I don't
know what to tell people but I don't
know what I mean even if it does this
the summer fall I mean we're just gonna
be we're gonna be you know from the
minute that we can see 20 21 which we
can't even see it now yeah but the
minute we can see it you know late
September acted like we're gonna be just
like get us there yeah because there's
no way that this year there's no way to
salvage this year truly there's just no
way there's just no way the damage being
done is gonna take months and years to
come back from are you scared you're
like a broken toy what do you think no
I'm not scared
I'm fine interesting now you could
because you kind of want it like your
whole thing's like you were brought up
to die your whole thing of being like an
evangelical Christian like every day you
just went to a place and they're like
you're going to die today and you're
like yes I will and then because that's
it you guys are almost wishing for death
on some whether you admit it or not you
kind of want to just die you want the
end times yeah yeah that's all you guys
want
you're just so ready for it you're like
it's time to die it's really strange you
know you're just preparing for this you
know you're just a Texas person I mean
there's something kind of nice about all
of this right no
unless you're very sick you know I mean
no I'm not really worried if I was 70 I
would be terrified right we just went
for a walk and there's way too many
elderly people out and about do you
think you know yes but you know also dad
age a lot of them are like path [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] it we were just walking in
Beverly Hills they're like I lived in
Beverly Hills my whole life if [ __ ] it
yeah yeah I ran a race you're 75 and
you're living in Beverly Hills it worked
out you know what I mean yeah like what
else do you want what else do you want
yeah what do you think's next you gonna
buy an estate on the moon it's over you
did it you know
that's our emergency podcast everybody
that's a front dude doctor on the front
lines Rhett don't [ __ ] look at the
gonna kill you that's a respiratory
therapist in a Long Island Hospital good
kid dude man not a kid he's overwhelmed
by what's going on brutally honest about
everything I'm like our health care
workers gonna stop coming in he's like
oh yeah that's when you really when you
have a shortage of Badgett and then a
shortage of workers it's like what have
they seen that they're like I'm not
gonna get this more than we have yeah
more than we have this whole thing of
it's just of by the way see it's just
the flu crowd is gonna go down in
history as like the stupidest and by the
way it was every was the media everybody
was like get the flu right and Trump
everyone's like it's the flu people
walking around in hazmat suits and ain't
the flu I almost wonder if they know
more than what they're telling us and
they want to avoid a complete run on the
banks complete systemic collapse
complete panic because it ain't the flu
it was never the flu yeah it's flu-like
symptoms but it's killing people four to
eight days it's it's a vicious bug
there's no seat like if there might be
season there might not be we don't know
you're the warm weather could help it
might not you know I mean
what climates what climate is it hitting
the hardest I don't know you told me the
other day you had a guy who told you
something but I don't know if it's real
why don't you repeat it anyway
supposedly it's the virus is worse in
certain parts of the world at a certain
humidity level and a certain temperature
and so if this is correct it's going to
hit hard probably in like DC and st.
Louis next if you look at the map you
said the Portland in New York have the
same yeah so like Seattle like if you
look at the map of like it hitting
Seattle in Portland in New York it's
like these are the areas that are gonna
it's gonna get bad why kinda picture cuz
the my arrives in a certain temperature
and humidity but this is just a theory
you know yeah it's a theory well then
everything's a theory at this point all
right we're gonna have Co vid 20 soon
we're gonna you know what's to be all I
should have asked him and I didn't ask
him what I should have asked him if the
mutation was but he's got enough
problems with what he's got right yeah I
don't want to start freaking him out
what what what happens when it mutates
Co vid 20 if you thought could in a
world where Co fit 19 was bad you have
no idea what's next
Co feed 20 the rock is just fighting
covent 20 yeah can the rock fight this
we haven't discussed that what about the
rock fighting this how about that just
beating the [ __ ] out of that little
green spiky ball yeah this is what
really is interesting when you talk
about what does humanity in it's like
we're all armed to the teeth
nuclear by the way hydrogen bombs
nuclear weapons I'm not even talking
about guns which we have to put we're
all armed to the teeth with nuclear
arsenals and what really undoes us is
you know a microscopic organism and it's
kind of what it's kind of what everybody
said would happen yeah it's what
happened before it's what happened in
1916 they had a little 1957 one - that
wasn't as bad but I mean this is kind of
I mean when you're young and you're in
school you learn about the Black Death
and the Black Plague well you learn
about climate breakdown you're like okay
once ice caps melt
there will be certain bacteria and
diseases and those that is in the ice is
that true thousands of years yeah and
will be we were watching that TED talk
on this remember yeah yeah we're going
into parts of the rainforest humans have
never been to and we have deforesting
things and coming in contact with things
we've never ever ever been in contact
with yeah and it's gonna be fun because
a lot of those things are gonna make you
know what's the new theory we learned
that there was a lab experimenting on
animals yeah there was a lab by Wu Han
the disease research facility similar to
a Plum Island and Long Island where
they're experimenting on animals are
there you know there's a disease
research facility animal testing
facility all these disease facilities
use them animals to a degree and that
somebody at the labs okay I'll make a
few bucks I'll just back door sell some
of these animals to the local wet market
which is why they killed that doctor if
they didn't kill that they killed the
doctor why did they kill the doctor if
there's nothing right to be covered up
here something's going on my friend's
mother my friend friend's friend
I don't know this woman but she's an oil
consultant which means you were in the
CIA
that's just what it means that's really
the truth I'm an oil console' I mean it
just means you're in CIA is what it is
um get out she thinks he's a bioweapon
and she said quote she's like yeah I
think it was a little whoop see and woo
him hmm
and she thinks she goes it's very
possible this is a bio weapon yeah cuz
that's where their stuff is in Wuhan oh
yeah okay there's a lot of scientists
that you know Chinese been trying to
poach scientists from America and that's
been you know we've been talking about
that so I mean that's the type of can
speed you wanted to talk intelligently
about conspiracies let's go there it
might be a bio weapon maybe it is in a
leak or something from the animal
testing facility somebody backdoors it's
like hey I'll [ __ ] sell this hmm
sell this bat to the market stop eating
bat but your
hungry they're hungry you know right to
eat and Pangolin
are they really I don't know what to do
well there's penguins in the market
people buy their scales huh what about
what about in Texas you guys eat
rattlesnake do you eat armadillos or no
no I don't think they eat armadillos the
rattling armadillos have like diseases
on them they have like leprosy
interesting like that we don't need
horny toads either good the armadillo is
like a little tank he goes mm-hmm you
did you see the one you're going out of
the time yeah they roll up in a little
ball are you an idiot sorry
put it back in I was doing an act out of
an armadillo yeah Bernie you get very
nervous when you get your ask to speak
um the armadillo rolls up and did you
play with them as kids you pick him up
no you're not supposed to touch them but
one time I got to pick up like a dead
one in my backyard interest cuz my dad
shot it with a shotgun because there's
digging holes in the backyard gotta get
rid of it and and bye armadillo you mean
black alright folks thanks for coming
we're all gonna die thank you